>> Tucker: WILL THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES
MERRICK GARLAND HAS ORDERED
FEDERAL AGENTS TO INVESTIGATE
PARENTS WHO DARED TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT THEIR SCHOOL BOARDS.
PARENTS ARE NO LONGER ALLOWED TO
SAY ANYTHING AND CREATE THE
SEXUALIZE THEIR CHILDREN.
COME TO MY VAN, I'VE GOT SOME
CANDY.
DON'T SAY A WORD!
ONE MOTHER IN CALIFORNIA CALLED
BRITNEY MIRROR NOTICE THAT HER
SCHOOL BOARD, SUPPOSED TO BE
EDUCATING CHILDREN, HAD INSTEAD
INVITED THEM TO A FAMILY FRIEND
OR STOMACH FRIENDLY DRAG SHOW.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID IN A RECENT
MEANING OF THE SCHOOL BOARD THAT
PROMOTED THE EVENT.
>> WHAT IS IT ABOUT A GROWN MAN
COSTUMED IN SPARKLY BRAWL WITH
AUGMENTIN, TOOK TAPE ON HIS
FRONT, WHILE SPREADING HIS FISH
EDITED LEGS AS HE RIDES ON THE
GROUND, GRINDING IS GROWING NEXT
TO A MINOR.
FAMILY-FRIENDLY?
WOULD YOU US AN ANSWER.
WE HAVE A CULTURE THAT HAS A
MASSIVE PROBLEM WITH
SEX TRAFFICKING AND CHILD.
BUT YOU MADE THE DECISION TO
FEATURE AN EVENT THAT HYPER
SEXUALIZE HIS CHILDREN.
YOU WILL PLEAD THE ACTIVIST CARD
FOR AN ALIGNED SURGICAL CENTER
AND FOR A 21 PLUS BAR.
IT MAKES YOU ACTIVISTS AND WE
WON'T HAVE THOSE SITTING ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD.
>> Tucker: BRITNEY MIRROR WAS
NOT ARRESTED APPARENTLY BECAUSE
SHE'S JOINING US TONIGHT AND
WERE GLAD SHE IS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
[LAUGHS]
THIS IS THE SCHOOL THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE EDUCATING YOUR
KIDS IN THERE SEXUALIZING YOUR
KIDS.
HAD YOU FIND OUT ABOUT THIS?
>> SO THE UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT
TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES TO SEND
OUT THE INVITATION TO ALL
FAMILIES IN OUR TOWN.
THEY HAVE AN APPROVAL PROCESS
THAT THEY VIOLATED.
IT SAYS IN THEIR RULES OF
CONDUCT THAT THEY CAN'T SEND OUT
ANYTHING THAT'S LEWD, POLITICAL,
CONTROVERSIAL.
AND THEY DECIDED TO SEND OUT ABU
BASH INVITATION THAT IS
SPONSORED BY A GENDER
REASSIGNMENT CLINIC OUT IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND A 21 PLUS
NIGHTCLUB IN SAN DIEGO.
SO DO STATE.
WE ASKED THE BOARD AGAIN AND
AGAIN TO RECONSIDER AND TO ISSUE
AN APOLOGY AND AN EXPLANATION
WHICH THEY DIDN'T.
THAT'S WHY WE DECIDED TO SHOW
UP.
I WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
THIS IS COMING TO EVERY SCHOOL
ACROSS THE NATION.
AND IF YOU THINK IT'S JUST GONNA
STAY IN CALIFORNIA, YOU'RE DEAD
WRONG.
IT'S COMING EVERYWHERE.
IT'S WHY WE STOOD UP AND SAID
WERE GOING TO NIP IT IN THE BUD.
WHEN I CAN PLAY BY THE RULES
THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO BE AFRAID
WERE GOING TO BE PUNISHED IF WE
DON'T SPEAK UP NOW.
I HOPE THIS BREEDS COURAGE FOR
PARENTS ALL OVER THE NATION WHO
SEE THIS TREND STARTING TO
CHANGE WHERE, LIKE HE JUST SAID,
OUR KIDS ARE NOT BEING EDUCATED
IN THE FUNDAMENTALS.
THEY'RE BEING HYPERSEXUALIZED
AND WERE DONE WITH THIS.
>> Tucker: HAS A DIFFERENT
FROM, DINO?
>> WELL, IT SOUNDS LIKE IT'S ONE
IN THE SAME.
THAT'S WHY I MADE REALLY CLEAR.
YOU CAN SLAP NET LABELS ON
ANYTHING, MAKE ANYTHING
FAMILY-FRIENDLY THAT YOU WANT.
AND THAT'S THE DANGER OF THIS
IDEOLOGY IS THAT WERE BEING TOLD
TO USE NEW TERMS AND NEW
LANGUAGE.
I THINK WE DO A DISSERVICE WHEN
WE PLAY BY THOSE RULES.
WE NEED TO STAND UP AND USE THE
WORDS THAT WE KNOW WHAT THEY
MEAN.
BUT THE ADULTS ARE OUT OUR KIDS
TO 21 PLUS NIGHTCLUBS.
IT'S COMING ALL OVER THE NATION
AND WE NEED TO NOW USE BRAVE
WORDS AND WORDS WITH MEANING AND
CALL IT LIKE IT IS.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I'VE SET A NONWATCHED PASSIVE
PARENTS LET CREEPY ADULTS
SEXUALIZE THEIR CHILDREN AND
IT'S SO GRAT